we're here to talk about Zelda because
Alexi your review for Zelda Majora's
Mask is going live on the site tomorrow
tomorrow at 8 a.m. Pacific time right
and when's an ass like that comes out
February 13th alongside the new Nintendo
3ds excellence your are you guessing
your embargo to actually talk about that
particular video game um I can't really
say much about it except that it is a
Zelda game and you prefer the 3d and
it's Majora's Mask right about Majora's
Mask though right Majora's Mask I can't
talk about Majora's Mask Majora's Mask
for people they don't remember is the
weird and Zelda game where this where
the moon speaking of the moon except we
cut the moon part of this probably so it
doesn't make any sense it's a mystery
yeah the moon is falling out of the sky
and Link has to save the world again and
he has to relive this 72 hour span like
Groundhog Day over and over and over and
over saving people getting things right
liberating spirits from temples typical
link stuff when the grand hug day like
on Monday there yesterday was bad okay
should have like maybe done a like the
Matic launch thing there just missed out
on awesome yes had done a takeover of
the moon a real angry face I think the
moon is so much falling out of this guy
as like face-planting out of the sky
like with real intent and I was I grew
up playing Commodore stuff so I was kind
of my like big guilt in terms of games
is not really getting like deep into
Nintendo stuff at least for a long time
until the Gamecube so the first Zelda I
played was winwaker and so i'm cut yeah
I know so I'm kind of interested in what
you guys think is like the like your
favorite cell the game and then maybe
let's talk about what you think maybe
like objectively was like the best Peter
what's what's your favorite Zelda eggs I
know you've played all of them mmm
almost all of them I skipped some of the
handheld ones like the Oracle of Ages
and right anyway yeah I mean like
growing up though my brother was much
older he owned a Nintendo I couldn't
help but be sort of thrust into Zelda
like the original The Legend of Zelda
and that I think is for me perhaps like
my personal favorite
it's it's a real close call between that
and I'll link to the past both of those
games are sort of they fall within the
classic Zelda formula before the series
went to 3d but they each have their own
qualities that are really great you know
the original one it was such a like you
didn't really have much context for what
was going on it was very mysterious and
you had this kind of an open world to
explore and tackle it in your own way
and that was such like a interesting
thing especially back then like just
that that sort of that quiet like
subtlety of like you know wide-open
adventure place it wasn't like segmented
into lever I mean there were dungeons
but you could just go all over the place
yeah and that kind of freedom was
incredible I mean people would like make
maps you would draw a map exact track of
stuff yeah but I think that kind of that
mystery worked against it in some ways
because I remember being over a friend's
house and they just like navigate like
four screens over three screens up and
then there's this Bush that's like the
fifth from the center on it and like
that's like a crucial part to getting
through the game turn how are you ever
gonna find that if you don't have
someone to tell you like I'm not that
just like for me so so aggravating it
was a game you think you can go back
like I could play for the first time in
2015 and enjoy it or do you enjoy it
because of its time and place in like
your own gaming history I think you
could go back and enjoy it but as Chris
was saying it can be a bit cryptic right
like there are moments like even just
the little messages that you read from
people they're likely to confuse you
more than they are to give you and you
started useful knowledge but that said I
think it's it stands the test of time is
like a great overhead 2d adventure game
Alexa what's your favorite a Zelda game
a lot of ones you played you said he
started with one Waker yes as your first
yeah I love winwakerwinwaker I think
that's my favorite Salda game I just
there's something about being able to
explore this enormous vast world and
having all of that water made it feel
much bigger than it probably already was
and riding around in this like sassy
boat and just like figuring out like oh
there's like another culture over here
on this island doing one thing and then
there's another culture over here and it
really felt like like I feel like this
world is lived in and has existed for
hundreds of thousands of years I also
like the way the game is segmented
they're sort of like through a sort of
three-part
to the game when the beginning you're
sort of figuring out oh I'm the hero of
time and I'm the kid and then the third
part is you know the the fetch quest
where you collect the things and awaken
the the temple of time or wherever the
king is and then there's the latter half
we're like the poop is hit the fan and
it's sort of this sense of urgency of
you know I have to save Zelda and I have
to save the world and I really like the
way that it's a sort of slow dramatic
build-up and then it lets you gives you
all these things to explore in the
meantime so it just felt big and amazing
I really enjoyed winwaker but because I
hadn't played any of the older ones I
kept hearing from people that like it's
not super popular in like Zelda circles
and I always wondered was I missing
something like what was it a bad
did you enjoy winwaker or like i
definitely enjoyed it i think originally
the bigger complaint was the the fetch
quest at the end that you were talking
about the Triforce little that's a big
pain in the ass yeah just the repetition
involved right yeah and even some of the
sailing for all this great qualities was
also a bit boring at times I think the
biggest backlash against Wind Waker was
for that art style people are like yeah
oh it's like a cartoon kiddie Zelda
after you know until after ocarina of
time after majora's mask which seemed to
sort of queue you up for something more
like twilight princess like that darker
like a more realistic I know it showed a
demo like before the game keepers out
very like realistic looking Zelda men
were hyped about yeah I personally loved
wind wakers art style and it definitely
ranks among my favorite but I also
really liked Twilight Princess okay
that's one that not a lot of people like
I mean certainly GameSpot got a lot of
crap for it I think yeah give it an
eight point nine I liked I thought it
was great because the character of Midna
was like an a companion character that
was really interesting and also the
villain in Twilight Princess was like a
legit kind of villain not just like I'm
I'm done and I'm the one who's always
been the villain um once I'm into a
giant pig demon and like that it was it
was similar to the villain in Skyward
Sword and that they were
weird they're a little bit unknown but
had personality in a really interesting
way yeah
let's say taking a little moment before
we talk about and perhaps the best one
to talk about what are the games that I
should stay away from if I'm going into
the back catalog of Zelda is there
anything that I should like stay the
goddamn hell away from that I might
think oh this looks interesting or neat
there are the obvious candidates I think
we all know the CDI zelda games oh yes
no those are fabulous please play oh my
god what were they calling there two of
them no there's three they're not
fabulous they're bad they're horrible
they're not fun there's nothing
redeeming other than the fact that
they're other [ __ ] bad and they're
wonderful because they're horrible don't
play the game just watch these clips you
can find them on YouTube someone like
cut them into a compilation that save
you yeah it's just amazingly bad what
does the gameplay like there it's yeah
there's some like really bad platforming
all of this makes French version of this
we have episode of Nick arcade like
that's what it looks like back wizard in
the middle hit that was it where would
you even could you even play this I
guess you were to emulate it yeah you
can burn CDI games you play under CDI
but you still own oh god I did play it
on a CDI thanks to Peter you brought one
in no or something yeah we did we had
one in the office
Peter set it up and it this is just it's
awful like the hit detection was all
over the place projectiles would just
disappear
it's no good what a shame it looks
alright for a game to come in 1993 right
right right like what you know it looks
pretty it's an experience what I what I
actually found interesting about the you
talking about winwaker was that that was
a game that people were open arms back
graphics in terms of like we just did
some b-roll for it there 2015 looks
pretty great yeah those those GameCube
games like that whole era that was d
remastered let's be fair
oh yeah super well as opposed to the art
style of ocarina which that does not
hold up well like that game looks really
pretty bad real gangster yes though like
the 3d version is great like they've
really live ended up in terms of the
detail the characters like
they that's the version to play like
don't try to play the n64 version again
yeah Chris what's your favorite or what
do you think is the best of all the
Zelda game if I could only play one well
if you could only play one because I'm a
jerk about like minutes to live no I've
got like 80 hours left to live I can
only play ones hour later you could only
play one you should get your 3ds and
play a link between worlds yeah because
that not only is a phenomenal game in
and of its own right but it and it has
the the some real clever mechanics in it
but it also harks back to what many
consider to be the best a Link to the
Past which was the Super Nintendo Zelda
which I never got proper chance to play
and still haven't sought it out much to
my great personal shame but that one
this sort of evokes that in in its style
and in the way that its world is built
but make some really neat sort of
innovations in terms of the openness of
the world and the way you move between
the two worlds excellent son of course
GameSpot's gave it here for 2013 it was
as well oh hell yeah
Alexa what do you think what is the one
that I should play if there was only one
to play only one I would have to say
link to the past actually it's just like
it makes you feel smart like like Chris
was saying about finding that fifth bush
in the whatever it makes you feel smart
I think it's a very well put together
puzzle game it's fun and also there's
just enough there but just enough not
there that you can sort of really use
your imagination and like dig into it
and I kind of like that it's it's does a
lot with only very little visually
excellent Peter we're gonna get a
hat-trick for a Link to the Past you're
gonna step out a Link to the Past but
for different reasons I think the way
that that game sets up the entire story
with you no link is sort of in this
little shack with his uncle
you know the uncle has to go to the
castle because something's afoot and
then link is kind of concerned so he
follows suit finds his dying uncle you
know uncle passes on the sword like you
kind of just infiltrate this castle and
then suddenly like you're sort of
responsible for yes saving the princess
the damsel in distress but you sort of
get this quest like just kind of given
to you and you sort of start off like
the others all the games right like you
beat a couple palaces of dungeons
whatever you get some pendants and then
the game is like oh by the way there are
two worlds hmm I guess you missed that
part
yeah No
not just one world there's two so it
that moment especially for me was when
that game kind of just took off like
great start great middle and then the
ending is pretty dramatic boss battle
that I thought was great as well
excellent alright well there you have it
that's our consensus I guess for the
best Zelda game
if you only have 80 errors left to live
or something if you have your own
thoughts which I'm sure you do
please put them in the comments below
and let's start that discussion right
now